You just had to look
at a smallpox sufferer
to be horrified.
It was very much a lottery ticket,
which most people didn't want to buy.
The eradication of smallpox
is one of the most
significant events
in the 20th Century.
For me it would be up there
with the moon landing.
You certainly couldn't miss a
patient who had got smallpox.
You had these blisters,
these lesions all over your skin.
All these pustules
were filled with virus.
India, as in the Mughal Empire,
understood the value of variolation
because it saw smallpox
as a threat to military power.
But the problem was that
it was as risky as it sounds -
you're basically trying to stop
a deadly disease by giving somebody
a mild case
of the same deadly disease.
Variolation could lead
to uncontrolled epidemics.
People knew that this was something
that their children would catch
and they might survive
or they might die from it
and so it was part
of the cycle of life.
When Jenner inoculated the arm of James Phipps,
a young boy of eight,
with the contents of a cowpox bled from a dairy maid,
it became possible for the first time to protect human beings artificially
against pathogenic organisms.
This really tipped the table in
favour of prevention and eradication.
To people in the 1700s,
this was totally mind-blowing.
Jenner's idea was a game changer.
What happens in 1948
after the Second World War,
the horrors of the Second World War,
is that the world agrees that
a new world order was needed.
What a crazy idea it would be
to say that you're going to institute
vaccination throughout
the entire world.
The 11th World Health Assembly
approved a resolution in 1958 calling for worldwide smallpox eradication.
The WHO galvanised enthusiasm,
they standardised the vaccine,
obtained the resources
that they needed internationally.
They really deserve
tremendous credit for that.
People running the programme
were going from
door to door with pictures
of a child with smallpox
and asking people in the community
if they knew anyone
who had this disease.
You're tracking, testing, isolating.
It's a strategy which
many people have said
will be the only way we can
keep on top of Covid-19.
May, 1980.
Two men affix their signatures to an historic document.
National and local health workers
played an immense role
in the eradication of smallpox,
whether it's in Africa or in Asia -
often selflessly, because
a disease like smallpox was
as threatening to them as Covid-19
is to today's health workers.
It's interesting that we're often so
eager to commemorate success in wars,
but that much less is done
to celebrate success
in the control of disease.
The eradication of smallpox
is one of the most
significant events
in the 20th Century.
For me it would be up there
with the moon landing.
We've eradicated smallpox.
And because we've eradicated smallpox
we know that we can eradicate
other human diseases.
If we all work together
to tackle the disease,
to stop it spreading,
to protect ourselves,
there is no reason why
we can't stop another pandemic
like we stopped smallpox.